kim kardashian opens up about her
boyfriend pete davidson for the first
time and reveals if he'll make an
appearance on her famous family's new
reality show we'll just have to wait and
see
the 41 year old skims founder sits down
with variety and talks all things the
kardashians her family's new hulu series
premiering april 14th you guys it's
happening
over the last year
we've seen such transformations from all
of us
and when asked if her new beau will be
involved she teases fans will just have
to see adding quote i'm always open and
honest and i'll never not be so you'll
definitely get that honesty and openness
when it comes to the relationship that
i'm in
i love that energy in my life the kkw
beauty founder adds that she will share
all the juicy details like how they met
who reached out to who and how it all
went down explaining quote i'm
definitely open to talking and i
definitely explain it
yes
although kim does admit she sometimes
wants to take a page out of courtney's
handbook and establish more boundaries
quote let me just live my best life
i'm just like living life and
whatever happens happens
yeah fans of keeping up with the
kardashians know that during its
20-season run kim's older sister
courtney made it pretty clear she didn't
love sharing every single detail of her
personal life on camera
in fact court wanting to quit the show
was an actual storyline on the series
i've decided to take a big step back
from filming and really
just pick and choose what i
will allow cameras to follow the push
founder eventually decided to stay on
the show but she established some
boundaries i'm just
decided to
spend more time as a mom and you know
put more of my energy there but i'm not
saying goodbye and it appears kim is
learning how to find a healthy balance
this time around too it's a different
experience for sure but i know what
you're wondering has pete films with kim
oh my god kim says not yet but she's not
opposed to it adding that it's just not
what he does but if they were at an
event together he wouldn't tell the
cameras to get away and in true
kardashian fashion kim served up the
ultimate tease quote i think i might
film something really exciting coming
but it wouldn't be for this season it
wouldn't reach until next season
well it looks like fans will just have
to tune into season one and two of the
kardashians to learn more about kim's
new love and we're not mad at it
[Music]
you